david morales son nom ne vous dit
peut-être pas grand-chose c'est un
ancien militaire espagnol devenu
dirigeant d'une société de sécurité
pour créer son entreprise under cover
global il s'est inspiré de blackwater
multinationale américaine de sécurité
privée est déployé en soutien de l'armée
américaine dans de nombreux conflits
notamment en afghanistan et en irak
under cover global a été chargé
d'assurer la sécurité de l'ambassade de
l'équateur à londres entre 2015 et 2018
mais son dirigeant s'est en fait révélé
être un agent double il aurait espionné
julian assange 24 heures sur 24 pour le
compte des états unis david morales a
ainsi fait installer des micros dans les
extincteurs de l'ambassade les aussi
dans les toilettes pour femmes ou les
avocats du fondateur de wikileaks se
rencontraient de crainte d'être
espionnés l'entreprise aurait même
qualifié le vol de la couche d'un bébé
pour effectuer un test adn afin
d'établir si le nourrisson présenté à
julian assange lors d'une visite était
son fils caché david morales fait
aujourd'hui l'objet d'une enquête de la
haute cour espagnole
une enquête qui fait suite à une plainte
de julian assange qui accuse david
morales et sa société à d'infractions
relatives à la violation de sa vie
privée et du secret de la relation
avocat clients ainsi que de détournement
corruption et blanchiment d'argent
ses avocats affirment disposer je cite
d'énormément de preuves
ils m'ont montré des images où nous les
avocats parlons à julian les appareils
des coûts que les appareils de
surveillance vidéo et d'enregistrement
c'est quelque chose de scandaleux
quelque chose qui n'arrive que dans les
films d'espionnage
mais ceci n'est pas un film d'espionnage
car la vie d'une personne est en jeu un
journaliste tout ce qui a été fait est
une persécution contre un journaliste le
rédacteur en chef de wikileaks pour
avoir rendu publics des faits terribles
des crimes contre l'humanité et des
processus de corruption
les agissements de david morales sont au
fur et à mesure montée en puissance
d'après des témoignages obtenus par le
site d'investigation de green zone le
bureau du principal avocat d'assange a
été cambriolée et quelques semaines
après que morales est proposé d'y entrer
par effraction
ces mêmes témoins ont aussi détaillé une
proposition d'enlèvement ou
d'empoisonnement de julian assange
un fonctionnaire équatoriens auraient
également été volées sous la menace
d'une arme alors qu'il était porteur
d'informations sur un plan visant à
obtenir l'immunité diplomatique pour le
lanceur d'alerté ce qu'on vient de
découvrir et grâce aux éléments de
l'enquète espagnol est absolument
révoltant ahurissant c'est une atteinte
très grave contre la souveraineté de
l'état équatorien sur son territoire est
une atteinte au droit international
malgré plusieurs éléments l'incriminent
ans david morales continue d'affirmer
que l'opération d'espionnage qui l'a
mené à l'ambassade équatorienne de
londres a été entièrement effectuées au
nom du sauna un service de sécurité
équatorien je ne peux faire aucune
déclaration sur ce que nous avons fait
là bas je ne peux pas donner de détails
nous avons nos règles éthiques et
morales et aucune d'entre elles n'a été
violée
l'enquète de la haute cour espagnole
doit permettre de révéler comment une
ses global a trompé le gouvernement
équatorien au nom du client au culte que
morales a plein
les amis américains julian assange et de
son côté aujourd'hui toujours incarcérés
dans la prison de haute sécurité de
belmarsh au royaume uni il craint d'être
extradé vers les etats-unis où il
encourt jusqu'à 175 ans de prison pour
avoir notamment divulgué
sept cent mille documents de l'armée
américaine classée secret défense